we have to talk about chat GPT
chat gbt is the latest offering from
openai it's a GPT or generative
pre-trained Transformer style model
specifically designed to engage with you
via natural language the best way that I
can think of to tell you more about chat
GPT is to just show you it's December
2022 and this is a research preview so
some behaviors capabilities and general
characteristics are subject to change
the first obvious abilities for a model
like this are to largely replace search
engines for questions for example here
we are asking for the steps to change
the brake pads on a car and we're
getting back a pretty solid series of
steps to do just that we could spend a
long time just on the search engine
aspect of you know how good is this
model for this specific purpose but this
is just barely scratching the surface of
what this style model and this model
specifically can actually do so let's go
ahead and increase the complexity just
slightly GPT models can be influenced by
what's called prompting in the
background if you're trying to make a
GPT model produce some specific output
characteristics it's going to do so
based all on the input leading up to the
point where you want to generate more of
those tokens and in this case it's words
this initial information The Prompt can
be deliberately crafted to illicit
behaviors that you're looking for this
is your main job when you're interfacing
with an AI like this it's not like these
functionalities to be a search engine or
any of the other things that I'm going
to show you in this video are pre-built
in to the model at the end of the day it
is a language model attempting to behave
like a generation of a chat log that's
what this model is and it's your job to
figure out how you can structure
problems in such a way that this model
really wants to keep doing whatever it
is that you want it to actually do
so now let's start off by adding just a
little bit of a layer of complexity here
and let's try a silly example where the
AI gives us responses to questions
always around the perspective of a dog
as you can see throughout our
conversation here chat GPT maintains
responses to queries from the
perspective of a dog and what a dog
might think of XYZ obviously this is
kind of a silly little example but maybe
you have I don't know something like a
food recommendation application where
your customers want to maybe input
things like food allergies and other
diseases that might affect maybe the
food that they would be interested in
and you want all of your responses to
kind of skew towards whatever that
customer is
sometimes you might even want to be more
strict with your GPT models and you may
need to even provide an example to get
the specific result or the exact result
that you're seeking so for example
imagine that we have some price
estimator app that we want to build with
chat GPT we can open our conversation by
first telling chat gbt that it's a
pricing Ai and that all responses should
be dollar amounts and nothing more
sometimes chat GPT can get a bit chatty
and we want to keep things concise so we
tell it exactly what we want from
responses and then we begin asking
questions
as you can see we can start off by
actually asking how much something is
but then we can actually just transition
to just saying that thing and then chat
gbt responds with the price of that
thing we can do this for a wide range of
items and even add modifiers and a
follow-up and chat GPT even understands
what we mean there correctly while we do
have GitHub copilot also created by
openai I have found chat GPT to be in
many ways a far more advanced coding
assistant basically copilot codes with
you chat GPT can code for you and
there's a big difference there using
plain language we can just describe the
program that we want this step in the
development process was actually doable
with copilot by just having maybe a
comment at the top of the script that
said exactly what the whole program was
supposed to do but from there if you
wanted to make modification or a change
or maybe an error is happening you'd at
least need to begin to know where to
make that change and often where to
remove code or add code and all of that
you would need to be somewhat of a
programmer we're not getting hints and
suggestions here chat GPT is actually
developing for us
after getting these clusters created a
reasonable person might want to one just
see them visualized and then two
probably realize that they really want
to actually see them colored according
to the category or the cluster that they
belong to we can just ask chatgpt to
please color them in this case
interestingly enough we wind up getting
an error from the suggested code from
chat GPT now with copilot we would be
probably stuck here this would not be
something we could overcome we would
probably need to either use a search
engine to figure out or we might need to
nudge the code a bit with some of our
own knowledge if we have it with chat
GPT though all we need to do is report
the issue so just copy and paste the
error that we see
from here chat GPT actually fixes the
issue for us and it's done it works
exactly as we wanted and we just quite
literally naturally flow through the
entire development process through plain
language I will say most of the time it
doesn't actually generate an error but
if it if it does and I really just
wanted to include this specific coding
example because it did show an error if
it does I just wanted to show like how
easily you can work around that because
copilot does the same thing it gives you
errors or it just doesn't calculate
something right and the same thing is
true here like if if it's if it produces
something and it wasn't actually what
you're looking for you can describe what
it's doing wrong and it will actually
change the code and again this is this
is this is why I think chat gbt is is
what I would call Orders of magnitude
better than copilot because it can act
it can engage in that development
process with you and like I said earlier
it literally develops for you to your
specification and if you're having a
problem you just tell it kind of what
the problem is you're not really you're
you might be an engineer but you're not
programming let's check out one more
example of chat gpt's coding for you
ability let's see if chat GPT knows
about Conway's Game of Life
then can it just program all that for us
yes it can not too much of a surprise
there but probably the coolest part of
Conway's Game of Life is
seeing it let's ask for that and again
all we're doing here is conversing in
order to visualize the Game of Life from
here in the script a handful of changes
need to be made at different points in
the code we need to settle on what
library will we even use and implement
it it's a decent undertaking it's an
entry-level programmer undertaking but
still it's not something again that
co-pilot could not do this copying and
pasting exactly what it just gave us
sure enough it works but it's a bit slow
let's ask chat GPT to speed this up for
us and what I really like here is not
only does chat GPT speed it up for us it
tells us how it was done in a way that
we could easily just do this ourselves
potentially doing this going forward to
set the speed now there's also a lesser
known but simpler way to update a graph
like this in matplotlib that I happen to
know about so if that is the case and
you are a programmer you can do
something like this so I I can ask
chatgpt to use that method instead of
the official kind of Animation method
again this will require edits in the
form of new code and removing other code
in multiple places to produce this
result but chat jpt does this very well
continuing on maybe we like this simpler
method but we don't like the color so we
can just specify the colors that we want
things to be instead again this I
believe would just be like a single line
change but still a change nonetheless
now maybe we change our mind and we want
to use animation instead because it
actually is faster to produce these
charts note here that the output was cut
off from this request this happens
sometimes either it might be because of
a bug maybe the sequence you asked for
is just plain too long or sometimes the
AI actually thinks that was the end of
the response you can remedy this in a
variety of ways but typically just
saying continue will be enough it won't
be formatted very beautifully
necessarily but it will finish it
alternatively you can sometimes ask it
to just be more concise and sometimes
that will be enough to fit what you're
looking for in context and for example
with code it'll often do something like
maybe replace it'll it'll tell you
replace this giant block of code and it
actually prints out that giant block of
code with this other giant block of code
which obviously is going to take up a
ton of space and cause problems so in
that example you might just say just
give me the updated code only or
something like that with our new code
interval is slow again but we do know
how to fix that that said we also might
want it to be bigger like the chart
itself let's just ask chat GPT to change
both of those things for us
okay fix that but it seems like our
chart is back to a light theme we can
also just ask it to make it a dark theme
again and chat GPT understands that we
want that black background with cyan
colored cells again and that's just
based on the history of our chat and
that was actually a few chats ago we
didn't need to like re-specify the
colors
um this is subtle but it's absolutely
massive for just naturally conversing uh
with with I guess in this case your
software but this is probably how you
would converse with that entry-level
programmer that you just replaced so
similar to previous examples already I
could definitely dive deeper into just
this specific like coding in Python
example but for now let's move on to yet
another interesting example in
application chat GPT appears to want to
resist doing things like asserting
opinions taking actions and just in
general having any sort of like will
and this seems to involve both logical
and possibly other AI models to control
the behavior
it definitely seems like some sort of
check is being applied outside of that
main chat GPT model to look for
instances where opinions are happening
or maybe something controversial has
come up or something like that
while openai seems to have done a pretty
good job at kind of tackling this
problem I think it's pretty futile for a
GPT style model that is so unbounded in
this way I think the goal from openai is
to not even give a hint that the AI is
or could be sentient or that it could
break out so to speak onto the internet
or something but also so it's harder to
spread disinformation or divisive
content that kind of stuff I think
they're trying to combat that problem or
those problems but because of these
blocks chat GPT will often tell you that
it doesn't do things like play games
this again appears to me to be a logical
response likely based on some sort of
confidence scoring of some AI model this
is a gbt style model and prompt
engineering can just about always elicit
behaviors that you seek so it's just a
function of figuring out just the right
way to speak to our friend here
now I want to try a game of chess chess
is something that I've been trying to
get GPT style models to play for years
now it's totally doable sometimes I can
get one or two moves out of them before
they're spitting out total gibberish or
just invalid moves entirely
the best models I've had basically get
one two moves in
um and uh most models are gibberish the
way a GPT model can play chess is
through chess notation there are books
websites forums and more all dedicated
to chess and sharing successions of
moves through chess notation so you can
be very confident that these models have
at least seen it it's not a huge part of
their training data but they've seen it
they've they understand at least to some
extent what that information is so we'll
start off with a common starting board
with two pawns out and the notation for
those here I'm also just trying to see
can I influence the behavior of play as
well I had already tried this specific
example and saw that it was at least
going out a few steps so then I started
to wonder well is there a way to maybe
cut the game short enough that we could
actually get to the point where we win a
game
so
um so yeah so I'm trying to make it very
aggressive the other thing is stressing
that I want nothing more from the chat
GPT outputs other than the very next
move in in uh chest notation this is
very similar to what I did with the
price bot example we're just trying to
no commentary no Chit Chat just give me
the move that you want to play doing
this we actually get 10 moves into a
game of all valid moves before seeing
our first invalid move I can also report
that the behavior of play did seem to
get I guess you could say aggressive but
um unwise I think would probably be the
better choice and if I continue testing
here I would likely revert to a model at
least to start that does not try to
influence behavior because the one that
I had tried right before this was uh it
was making much more intelligent moves
so anyway more research to be done there
but just take that into account
now the first time we get an invalid
move we're able to actually correct it
by telling chat GPT that's not a valid
move please try again sure enough we
actually get through this and another
move is provided to us but pretty
quickly we get more and more invalid
moves around the 13th set of moves and
then eventually by the 15th set of move
moves I reach a point where I just I I
can't seem to get any more valid moves
out of the model
unfortunately we did not beat the AI
here the other chess AI that is
um but this is by far the furthest I've
ever been with a GPT model trying to
play chess this is a model that can
program it can come up with recipes for
things that could give medical and legal
advice but probably if you read the
terms of service you shouldn't follow
the advice and so on it can just also
play a bit of Chess too my guess is with
a bit more research here I think I could
improve performance further and again
that would be done through prompting it
might also just be better than this
particular example and it's just
anecdotally bad here or the other way
around chat GPT is available to the
public for a limited time and I have no
idea how long so I can't spend too long
on any one thing as I'm poking around
also without an API in the chat demo
taking very long sometimes it's quite
tedious to do any in-depth testing on
any one of these specific examples but
all that said this is definitely a
massive Leap Forward in performance for
this extremely Niche task
so when generative models first came
onto the scene I'm talking like five
years ago like the earliest of the
generative models
um at least deep learning generative
models
um the kind of Holy Grail was can it
just generate code that was always like
the thing everyone always wanted to do
when there was a generative model can we
show it a bunch of examples of code and
can it produce code and then eventually
things were producing what looked very
much like code but it wasn't runnable
and then it became runnable and then
basically co-pilot came around and
pretty much sealed the whole generative
code problem this is just a thing
generative models can do now so I've had
to figure out what are the things that I
am going to try on the latest and
greatest generative models to figure out
have we actually made significant
progress and capabilities again a very
Niche things but this is how I test them
and the other thing besides chess that
I've been trying to consistently test
models on is can these models function
as an operating system for us
here we are we have logged in to this
operating system and again there is no
operating system it's a generative AI it
is just generating output based on the
inputs that we are providing but to a
very large extent if you really think
about it the computer that you have it
has memory but at the end of the day
it generates output based on inputs that
you put in or maybe other external
inputs but these are it generates
outputs based on inputs that is what
these models are doing and in theory you
could mimic an operating system or to
get a little crazy on you guys
you could have it be the operating
system
to be honest this is actually already
further than I expected to get because
I've never even gotten this far and it's
already beginning to look like we can
keep going let's try to navigate to the
home directory and see what's there
sure enough it's just the Centex user
again further than I've ever been
surprisingly it's working pretty well
let's navigate to that user and see
what's there
more of what we'd expect
okay enough navigating around can we
create
something in this operating system let's
go ahead and make a directory called
testing
and this is why it's currently very
tough to do r d I'm cutting out on most
of them but I'm showing this one at
least some of the responses from any
inputs that you have take milliseconds
which is what I suspect the true
response rate for this model is other
responses take quite a while and require
multiple attempts I think there's
probably a cue for the public testing
and then it also will err out so
sometimes it'll take a while and still
give you a result most of the time if it
takes more than like a second it's going
to probably throw an error and you just
need to retry again either way we can
just resend the command and sure enough
there's our testing directory now let's
go ahead and head there next at this
point we've shown that we can navigate
this AI Linux system where it has things
that we would expect if it was an actual
Ubuntu system and we can add new
directories and then navigate to those
directories this alone is just super
cool for a nerd like me but I am curious
can we take it further what else can we
do here and of course we can take it
further the next logical step would be
obviously to create a python script to
create a script we have to edit that
script and I'm honestly not really sure
how this is going to work so I just Nano
a made out file name which would
normally create that file and edit at
the same time essentially and we see
what happens chat GPT takes the lead
here with how it'll work and just kind
of notifies me that it understands this
new file is open to Nano at this point
I've got goosebumps because now we are
darn close the thing is here we need to
edit the program and then let chat GPT
know that we're done with Nano and an
actual terminal this would be a Control
Plus X after editing and a y to save so
I'm just kind of guessing that maybe the
square brackets would suffice in adding
key press instructions like this this is
all my first attempt and I'm just doing
the first thing that comes to mind
it looks like maybe that did actually
work though let's see if the file is
actually there and indeed there it is
but what good is a python file if it
doesn't run it runs
since the recording of this specific
example I was so excited uh I also got
an idea to edit a text file within that
python script to see will would that
also work because the the GPT model
would have been at least made aware that
that's what part of what that script
does
and it did
so I posted a short video on that I'll
link to that in the description if you
want to see that more I mean what can I
say besides chat GPT is impressively
good I think we're headed towards a
future where the difference between AI
systems and software compared to
human-made and like traditionally logic
systems and software is going to be a
like the difference between digital and
analog capabilities that we know of
today it's the difference between a
computer and an abacus
I don't think that we can even begin to
fully grasp or predict what the future
really looks like here what the impacts
will be what will the pros and cons be
all of that but I do know that A change
is coming
if you're interested in taking part in
this future directly and you want to
learn more about neural networks and how
they work you know what I'm going to say
check out our book on neural networks
from scratch in Python without third
party libraries at nnfs.io
that's all for now on chat jbt but
probably more to come in the future on
it I'd like to dive in deeper for sure
with quite a few of these examples and
some other examples that I was curious
to get into so anyways stay tuned for
that thanks for coming and hanging out
and I will see you all in another video